foreign
welcome everyone to today today's
meeting of the licensing board welcome
back returning members and officers and
we have some new licensing members so I
think it'll be a good idea for everyone
to introduce theirself so everyone knows
who who everyone is can we start with
the officers please
hi hello again I'm Alison Brock
technical support team manager
oh
good morning oh my name's uh Alison
Stocker sorry another Allison and I'm
the senior licensing officer for
obviously for thanet District Council so
my main reamer is enforcement so I will
be dealing with all the scrap metal
taxes
um alcohol yeah any anything really
tattooists anything that needs a license
then I'll be out and about making sure
everything's done correctly
morning everybody I'm Morgan Sprouts I'm
the regulatory services manager so I sit
over environmental health and Licensing
officers are also in my team and yeah
I've just come along today
um to
observe some of the um some of the cases
and obviously the change in policy
that's been put forward as well thank
you
good morning Council to John Dennis
Garland Ward
good morning Brenda Rogers Peg one Cliff
send morning all Becky Wing Central
Harbor Ramsgate
hi I'm Cedric County councilor for
cliftonville East
Harry Scobee cliftonville
Sam knows it's Montefiore
Deborah Owen Hughes northward Awards
good morning councilor our Central
Harbor omsky
uh cancer Karina Huxley eastcliff
wolframs gate thanks
I'm councilor Alan Curry cliftonville
West and chair of Licensing
my name is Steve Steve Matthews I'm your
Democratic Services officer covering
licensing for today
good morning my name is Joseph kutangai
I'm your senior litigation lawyer thank
you
thank you everyone a little bit of
housekeeping now if the fire alarm is
activated please take the stairs down to
the reception area and out of the
building to the Green in holy Square
which is the assembly point please do
not use the lifts officers will assist
you and advise when it is deemed safe to
return to the council offices
I would advise that if filming takes
place anyone in attendance in the public
area may have their image captured I
urge anyone filming proceedings to avoid
filming members of the public
particularly if there are children
present does anyone intend to film the
meeting
so no
would everyone present please ensure
that their mobile phones are turned to
silent and that they are not used to
make or receive phone calls while the
meeting is in progress
I wish to inform members that due to a
clerical error
error
I've got the era here the clerical era I
think it's an error we don't what we
don't want an era a gender
a gender item nine was not added to the
full agenda until yesterday afternoon as
a result agenda item 7 exclusion of
public and press will now apply to both
agenda item 8 and item 9. can members
please make note of this
apologies I have apologies from
councilor Bainbridge
are there any more apologies
and we we do have one or two members who
aren't here today traffic is quite bad
so uh we we hope that a couple of
members might show up soon
sorry
um I believe um Linda Wright put
apologies to Sam bambridge but she tried
to ring me and it was difficult
um appearing on mobile
apologies she's not here can you make
apologies please counselor right
uh Declarations of Interest are there
any Declarations of Interest councilor
scoby
yes I need to declare an interest in I
think it's eight and nine so I will
leave at after item seven
thank you councilor scoby
um please can I have a member propose
and second that the minutes of the
licensing board meeting held on the 18th
of April 2023 be approved as a correct
record
councilor Huxley thank you
item four
changes and updates to licensing
officers enforcement policy please can I
ask Miss Allison Stocker senior
licensing officer to present the port
report
lovely thank you chair good morning all
um as per my report please find the
licensing officer enforcement policy due
to the length of time it's been in
operation legislation has changed and
the policy needs to be updated the
options are set out at the bottom of my
report which are 3.1 and 3.2 thank you
I propose chair
as as to uh that's 3.1 yeah to um a
greedy uh policy
um
seconded by councilor Ara
drive this downstairs as well uh yeah if
you could join the meeting councilor
manners thank you
[Music]
it's a lot of confusion there
um
[Music]
so 3.1 proposer councilor Wing seconded
by councilor Huxley thank you very much
uh item five
driver Knowledge Test
please can I ask Miss Allison Brock
technical support team manager to
present the report
good morning everyone
um as some of you will remember back in
March we bought a report to board about
the knowledge tests following
representations from some of the local
operators
you agreed some decisions at the board
to drop the second test down to Half
Price uh to look at the options of an
evening course
with immediate effect to add an online
safeguarding course which is basically
was an online classroom version so the
trainer could actually see who is taking
the course because the previous one was
on there
um anybody could have taken it for
anybody basically so that's in place now
and then going forward was to look at
changing the Knowledge Test maybe
bringing in a one-day course so that's
what I've got before you here is a
one-day course with a company called
Green Penny they actually come they
would come here to the offices or they'd
find their own venue they do up to I
think it's 12 people a day and they'd go
through the whole thing all the
safeguarding you know driver awareness
they do all sorts of things during the
whole day and then at the end of it they
do a test
for the drivers we can add to that we
can add our own little local Knowledge
Test and also they can do an English
test as well if they feel necessary for
certain applicants
so the options are basically to leave
the knowledge test as it currently is
or we trial the green Penny one day
course we have made some slight changes
to the current tests we've changed some
of the questions because some of them
were a bit odd a bit ambiguous so we've
changed quite a few of them
um so your options now are we leave the
current course as it is or we go and
trial a one day course thank you
thank you Alison
um I imagine
um members would like to debate this or
ask some questions
hello
you talk about the option for English
tests I think you should have that as a
matter of fact because there are a lot
of overseas drivers around the area and
I think that would be helpful especially
there are a lot of elderly people that
use taxis and you know they need to
communicate and I think that's an
important aspect of it thank you
cancel the wing
uh how will we ensure that an external
company is delivering at the same
quality and I've been on one day first
aid courses where you know nobody's
going to fail unless you're absolutely
ridiculous but it does concern me that
we're putting people behind the wheel of
a car and also I'd like to follow up on
the communication I don't necessarily
think it's just about being able to have
been able to
speak in English well enough to
communicate with people it's all also
around the style of communication people
may have
is there a customer care element of it
I'm particularly concerned because a lot
of people who use our taxis are
is under the influence of alcohol or
their elderly or they've got
disabilities or their parents with
children so there's a degree of
vulnerability that comes around many
people that use our taxis
yeah I mean in the actual
um the standards that the the government
recommend they do actually recommend an
English test so that is something we do
want to bring in
um within the course you can see they've
got um disability inequality awareness
they've got this safeguarding
responsibilities
um you know how to report a crime the
highway code they cover all of that and
customer care so we can basically tailor
this
so what we see fit for here they do do
this is a course that is used by other
councils currently
am I assuming you said you'd monitor I'm
assuming you you'd actually maybe have a
little highlight by the side of these
drivers to see if there are any
benefits or non-benefits moving forward
yeah I mean for the first couple of
times that we that the courses run we'll
probably have myself or one of the team
will sit in
um and they will come and do a
demonstration of the course if you
wanted that
I don't think you want to sit there for
a whole day but they could come and do
uh maybe next what's it July one isn't
it they might be able to pop along and
do a little demonstration of what they
actually include in the day course for
you
toe
Allison is also off state of
um you know companies like that I mean
how if there were concerns could you go
back to them so do you look at how they
perform do you get feedback from the
people who take the tests things like
that
we obviously speak to the councils Who
currently use them there only seems to
be a couple really this blue pen um
green Penny and Blue Lamp trust
obviously at the moment the safeguarding
course that's online is either with
green Penny or Blue Lamp they seem to be
the main two
um to firms that do all of this so
they're used by a lot of a lot of other
local authorities
yeah apologies for joining the meeting
late we were we weren't told it was here
we were both sold I guess because we're
new members we're probably not on the
system
um anyway
um yeah that my question was
um the uh the element of knowledge
that's in the exam at the moment is that
going to be part of the one day course
I've I've kind of caught the tail end of
this so I wasn't sure what what the
situation was there
yeah we can add the local Knowledge Test
onto this a couple of the other councils
that use it do have their own little
knowledge tests at the end so that's not
an issue we will be putting local
knowledge on there because I think it's
important
so will the local Knowledge Test stay
the same as the local Knowledge Test at
the moment or will it be a simplified
version
I would think it would I'd have to
obviously have a chat with them see how
many because obviously at the moment
we've got we got on there 40 the 20 or
40 no 20 Questions isn't it so we may
cut that down a little bit but the ones
that are on there at the moment are
where such and such a pub or where such
and such a hotel and then we give them a
multiple choice of where they are so
that's what we do now so we'll
definitely have some form of local
knowledge on it
councilor Owen Hughes and this Falls
really nicely for me in the previous
life I used to be a Department of
Transport driving Examiner
so I'm really interested in uh in the
test and the training um before so
before we make any decisions is there a
way we can have a look at it or go see
them or
they will come and do a demonstration if
you wanted to obviously this course
doesn't include
driving it's purely sitting in a
classroom base and going through all the
all the side of it but we wouldn't be
able to obviously bring that along until
hopefully the July board meeting
just to pick up from that
um from the enforcement side if we bring
drivers to board with regards to their
driving abilities we do have an option
on there for them to take a driving test
or you know moving on and having a an
extra test I think it is actually with
green Penny as well so that's the way
that we would deal with that we would
ask them to do a test so
that's a telling
do all these taxi drivers have British
driving licenses
no they don't have to necessarily
why is that
if it's a European license
they don't have to do they
so the problem that we are having is
that a lot of drivers take a a test if
you like abroad they then come can come
over to this country and convert their
license to a British driving license
which then enables them to work to drive
obviously on our roads and once they've
held that driving license for a while
they can work as a taxi driver
how long is that valid for that because
I tell you what I have a home in
Portugal and it restricts me as to how
long I can drive on my British license
in Portugal and then I have to have a
Portuguese license eventually do the
women part of Europe so do we apply
anything like that
no I mean as Alison said basically they
if you've got a license in say Poland or
somewhere you come over here and then
you just convert it to a British license
they don't as far as I know have to do
any form of driving test like we do to
get our license
foreign
yeah one a question following from uh
councilor towning
um is there any verification procedure
to make sure that their license is
actually valid that
um it's not a Photoshop license do we
have any way that we know that these
people have taken a proper driving
course in in the country that issued the
license
we obviously see all the paperwork we
have to see all the originals of
everything and we can do online checks
as well if we need to
Castle Wing uh just to sort of after
four years we have had drivers in here
and we've forced them to undertake a
British driving license so that that
that is that is part of the tool of of
enforcement that we can use as a
committee uh the you know the vast
majority of our taxi drivers are
responsible on the road unfortunately
like everything else we have a number a
small minority taxi drivers who think
they can be above the law so I feel
quite confident that we've got in place
at check-in systems and a way of
enforcing and it's invariably a very
positive you know we don't want to not
have taxi drivers because we've got a
huge shortage of taxi drivers so I sit
here quite confident that although we
would accepting foreign licenses that uh
we we have all the things in place to
keep people as safe as possible on as
taxi drivers
cut some manners
um just following on from the new the
proposed course
um assuming the driver pitches up and
he's got all these documents in order
and he's competent to pass all the
relevant examinations and tests that
might be put in front of him what would
be the time scale from initial
application to receiving his license
under the proposed scheme versus the
existing scheme
well basically that they're no different
I mean
you the the main thing that holds up a
driver getting their license is getting
their DBS back from the DBS checks we
have no control over that
they can apply for their DBS now and
then they could take the test in two
weeks time
if their DBS hasn't come back there's
nothing we can do
it's very difficult to speed up the
process but if with this course in place
if somebody previously had got their
medical and the medical was dated within
a month because that's what it has to be
we'd got their DBS and their DBS has to
be dated within a month as well if not
they can sign up for the update service
which is what we're trying to encourage
everybody to do because shortly we're
going to have to be checking everybody's
DBS every six months
which is quite an onerous task for us
but that's why we need them to be on the
update service so we can just log on and
check them on the update service so if
they if they have their medical in place
if they've got their DBS if they then
pass this course they could have their
license in theory the next day
can I just uh
ask a question here um going back to um
the the knowledge questions I remember
the previous
licensing meeting The Operators were
saying some of the licensing questions
were difficult and we agreed to look at
them and I know you and your team
Allison have tweaked some of the
questions uh just just to confirm that
though that the new Knowledge Questions
will be forwarded onto the the new green
Penny test by yourself and the team
we will have this have discussions with
green Penny and see how they feel
they feel the best way to go forward
with all the things that they do on here
they do cover everything that we cover
in our current test and probably more to
be honest
uh Mr katangi yes uh just for guidance
um just to assist the board the board
should consider whether if the board
agrees to a green Penny one day course
is it likely to increase uh Public
Safety so that's a main question for the
boards consider thank you
canceling could I maybe suggest that we
agree to that we agree to the changes
but we review in a year's time so that
so that we get a chance to come back and
and look at how this is happening
anything that can increase driver
knowledge but also enables a flexible
approach to people accessing the chance
to train and be a taxi driver is got to
be a positive thing but I don't want us
to just run down a run down an alley and
not review it so maybe suggest that we
agree to the changes and review in a
year's time
I believe that if we did agree to the
the green Penny test this would take a
while to implement anyway so we we would
remain with the old format for some time
that's the Huxley we have asked as
cancer Deborah Owen husic we have a
demonstration from them sometime so that
we know what the drivers are going to
have to take thanks yep I can try and
get that arranged for the next um the
next meeting if possible
um members uh the the options are to
leave the knowledge test as it currently
stands or agree to the green Penny one
day calls to be started as soon as
possible and this could include uh some
caveats that we could add so
um does any member want to propose one
of the options
3.1 thank you
you can't catch the scope
sure can we have a carrot that we come
back in a year's time and review it as
Council Wing has suggested
and that we have a view of the
we have a demonstration of green Penny
course Anderson could we add that and if
you could draw that up yeah okay um
service
let me just check that
3.1 or 3.2 thank you Mr councilman
agree to the green Penny one day course
to be started soon as possible 3.2 thank
you
um so moving on to item six
um licensing and gambling statement
reports please can I ask Miss Alison
Brock technical support team manager to
present the report
Moon hello again
um it's a bit short one this one um as
you can see every Council has to have a
licensing policy statement and a
gambling policy statement and ours are
out of date at the moment the actual
content of them as such isn't out of
date really because the gambling act
hasn't changed since it first came in
um their the gambling Act is being
looked at at the moment and we've got a
meeting I think it's the 22nd of June
with regard to some changes that might
be coming for it so what I'm just
basically asking with these two policies
if you'll agree to them being in place
for another 12 months and then obviously
as soon as the changes are made with the
gambling gambling policy via the
government and with some that are
looking with the licensing policy we
will we'll start work on them
immediately and have them all ready to
go
thanks
the recommendation to the committee
members is to consider the report and
provide recommendations to officers
going forward would members like to
debate this item no the options are to
agree to the statements being in place
for another 12 months or to not approve
the extension of the current statements
does any member want to propose one of
these options
product codes 3.1
thank you councilor scoby can I have a
second though cancel the wing thank you
uh two members all agree
thank you
agenda item seven exclusion of public
and press
um
we we don't have any uh
public and press here
okay
um
uh please can I I have a member proposed
and second that the public and press be
excluded from the meeting can I have a
proposal please Council Rogers and a
second uh councilor wing
to members agree
thank you